hi guys this is luca from
lucalampano.com and i'm very pleased to
be here with lamont from the channel
days of french and swedish hi lamont
how's it going good thanks buddy how are
you
good good how's it going down under
because you're in australia right yes it
is spring and it's very wet and
but a nice temperature but yeah it's
going well
fine fantastic
so um lamont is a very interesting guy
he talks about language learning on his
channel but also about other things and
he's got a very very very interesting
vision um and perspective on language
learning and not only on language
learning so if you haven't started
following his channel
yet you should do that without further
ado let's get started let's dive in the
interview this is going to be um you
know we're going to cover some
interesting topics hopefully interesting
for you
um about language learning and not just
about language learning
so let's get started i have a list of
questions here
the first question is
lamont how have you
how has language learning impacted your
life
let's say how has language learning
second language acquisition language
learning in general
change the way you live the way you
learn the way you act
um
it it's almost like how has it not
impacted my life would be a much quicker
question to answer because for whatever
reason until i was like
30 i just didn't do any
kind of anything that was difficult at
all like i just didn't
i'd never got up early i never worked on
anything i never pursued anything
creative i just expected the whole world
to just come to me and
and i just for some reason one day is a
short way to say it i started learning
swedish and i guess the thing that's
interesting about learning foreign
languages is that
you're never very good at it
and like even if you are very good at it
you're actually not nearly as good as a
native speaker normally
so i think it
at the end of my first year of swedish
i sort of realized okay this takes
really deliberate
effort like unless i'm unless i'm just
going to give this up like i have
everything else i need to
really focus on this and i need to start
thinking about how i spend my time like
you know because i could i could do this
or this is so that every everyone could
do anything but
if i'm going to get good at this i need
to
think about what parts of my day i'm
using like when am i most awake and
and how how to use that time valuably
and then with youtube which came a year
or so after that
it did the same thing with so i started
talking about language learning on
youtube but um
doing language learning
and doing youtube and like just keep i
keep sort of adding every time i get a
little bit comfortable i add something
and so it's just completely changed how
i do everything in terms of i'm very
deliberate now i'd i'd i'm always trying
to move towards some goal
and i wasn't at all in my 20s like
just not even slightly so
whether it was language learning or
whether it was just going to happen
anyway
that's how it's impacted me
so you thought that before you started
seriously started learning languages you
thought that
you would just
get to it and you would learn the
language
just by getting exposed to the language
itself was that what you were thinking
in general
uh
no i
i
do me uh
no i i didn't take it seriously at all i
didn't really take anything seriously i
never put any effort into anything
because with with putting effort into
something comes the risk that you might
fail so
everything everything that i started to
get a little bit good at
i would
leave probably for that reason i like i
didn't know that at the time of course
but i probably as soon as i started to
get a little bit good you start having
this pressure and this expectation of
yourself and and i would leave it alone
and for some reason with language
learning maybe because i started talking
about it on youtube i don't know i i
thought oh hang on i need to actually
do this deliberately i can either go or
i can go back and pursue something else
that i've been
semi into in the past like music or
something um
but but i sort of decided to focus uh
more on languages but i know i didn't i
didn't really believe that i had it in
me to learn a foreign language
um
not because like talent i just didn't i
i didn't think that i had the stuff you
know like that the grit
um
so i guess it was
it was sort of an experiment to see if i
really could do it
yeah very interesting you used a couple
of interesting words here um which are
grit
and then you talked about
learning deliberately what do you mean
by learning deliberately and what how
does that impact
language learning now i know we're
opening a can of worms here
but um you know i've been watching a lot
of videos and reading a lot of books
about second language acquisition and i
guess you've done also some research on
that
and um there is this um comprehensible
hypothesis right that if you uh get
exposed to content that you're that that
is both compelling and understandable
then you're going to basically learn uh
the language but the liberal practice is
something where you have to sit and
deliberately engage in activities where
you know where you're focused and you
aim at something specific so
do you think that deliberate practice is
that important to language learning or
do you think well you just if you expose
yourself to the right stuff and you do
the right things and you talk to people
then
it's inevitably you're inevitably going
to learn the language anyway i know that
this is opening a can of worms but
you know
i think that mostly you're going to get
quite good if you just expose yourself
to enough of the language and
have conversations even every now and
then i don't think they need to be
regular and i think that most
uh western europeans from from countries
like germany and denmark and sweden and
stuff are
basic
basically proof of this in english in
that most of them can speak very very
good english and
a lot of them haven't
had that much deliberate kind of
practice
uh on it but
um
i was i guess i first of all i was
actually talking more about the fact
that i didn't i didn't even have a goal
to do with anything so i didn't
deliberately swear even if we even if we
say okay it's all just passive and you
can just watch compelling input
uh
i wouldn't have watched anything before
unless i wanted to watch it like and
like it basically if it was in a foreign
language
then i wasn't watching it to learn the
language i was just watching it because
i wanted to watch it like i watched the
bridge
a couple of times but that's just
because i liked it it's not because i
wanted to learn swedish or danish i
couldn't have even told you that those
two languages were different before i
was
into languages um
so i i more meant the like having a
deliberate approach to my life
uh as opposed but now i'm only really
just getting into the realm of
deliberate practice because i would say
that
i've only now
come to the point
where that's what's going to improve my
swedish before i'd say just my exposure
to swedish had not been enough
um and that's only i would i've really
only changed my view on this in the last
kind of 18 months or so i used to be
trying to learn the language very
uh like it was maths like
and put this here and put this here and
then try to assemble that as i speak
and it's only in the last 18 months that
i've just thought no i've just got to
get swedish streaming through my brain
all the time
gotcha um
thanks for the answer um one one
observation is that you were you were
talking about the bridge the bridge is a
tv series uh both in swedish and in
danish i think it's 60 in swedish and 40
percent in danish talks about the you
know something that happened on this
bridge that connects the two countries
and it's a very interesting show i i saw
i watched some of it i don't know if
you've watched the entire series and if
i hadn't known like like back in the day
i would have thought danish was some
kind of weird swedish because they speak
both languages and you get confused
anyway it's unrealistic how much they in
the show how much they can understand
each other in real life they use a lot
more english than in that show but
absolutely especially because swedes
have a hard time understanding danes and
danes
understand swedish much better
but we're going to talk about that
another another time so
one thing that really struck me because
i've been watching uh binge watching
your videos lately because i find them
very interesting is um that you said
something that struck me and that
happened to me as well let's talk about
deliberate practice and you know simple
practice i distinguish these two modes
of learning right you do something just
for the sake of doing it as if you were
doing in your native language like
reading something for the sake of it or
watching a movie just for the fun of it
um you said that you had been doing at
the beginning i remember you you talked
about it in a video about the
comprehensive comprehensible input you
said that you were an advocate of a the
more i speak from the very beginning
tell me if i got it right you thought
maybe a couple of years ago
that the more you engage in
conversations the better and faster
you're going to learn but then you
realize that after a lot of
conversations your level was kind of
stalling is that correct that's right
that's what happened to me i just
realized okay well i'm i talked to my
two hungarian tutors
and my my level just told and i realized
that i need more input so
um the main idea that i always tell my
students and let me know what you think
about it is that no matter what happens
input still remains the most important
the most powerful
source of
um you know of improvement let's put it
this way because anything that you do on
top of that like deliver practice is
fantastic right especially at this stage
where you get a b2 and you want to move
to a higher level
but don't you think that input should be
the main um let's say the foundation of
your second language acquisition of
language learning um
especially at the beginning
i do
uh but i think a lot of people are very
i do think that and i think a lot of
people are very um i don't know
even just the sound of like the the
input hypothesis or whatever they they
get very caught up in like labels and
they go like oh no but you also you also
need to speak and stuff and it's like
yes you do also need to speak especially
if you want to be really good and you
want to be able to express yourself very
fluently like for example luca in
english
he doesn't he he's much more fluent than
i am in swedish because
because he's outputted a lot but he's
done that on top of this input he's got
this subconscious understanding of how
english works to the point that
when when he comes to express a meaning
he doesn't need to think oh but what
about
do they conjugate this verb with that
verb with this person or what's going on
here it just all just flows out and that
in my experience takes a lot of input
and it didn't matter how much swedish i
spoke because i used to speak a lot like
a lot every day for an hour generally
and didn't matter how much i did that i
was always kind of assembling the
language as i went and going uh now i
need to say this and now i need to say
this
and not only does that not sound very
swedish
but it's it also never really gets you
any further like you've
you've basically you can only say things
that you've said before
yeah that's absolutely true it's
implicit in explicit learning so when
you're
thinking consciously thinking what kind
of grammar structures am i
am i using it's really difficult to do
it on the fly when you're talking to
someone so i believe that you learn
language both implicitly explicitly i
recently found a very very interesting
presentation by a japanese linguist on
on youtube i would link i would put the
link in the description box
where he
talks
at length about all the models that we
have um for example krashen's model and
he talks about the fact that now
that model is kind of old with respect
to other things and i do believe and by
watching that uh the video realized that
actually um my vision of things is that
you mainly learn languages implicitly
but you also have to learn them
explicitly and you need the right
balance and this balance depends on the
face it's a very interesting video i
recommend you to watch it i'll you know
i'll send it to you
but fundamentally to just to address
this question might from my perspective
is that you need both you need to
have a lot of input and learning
implicitly but you if you want to get
really good past the so-called b2 level
where you can interact with other people
and you know the language fluently you
speak effluently you need to do
something else
you need to engage in deliberate
practice come come to think of it
that's what you've done in your native
language right uh lamont i mean you've
been speaking with people you've been
learning english within your family and
with your
but then you've learned to read and
write at school
so
you know you've done a number of things
that you would not normally do
in your real life if we're learning a
foreign language say swedish have you
done like have you written dissertations
of given presentations in swedish
i'm still sort of deciding which of
those routes i want to go down like
but i'm starting to do
more difficult things i started to
slowly translate a book from english to
swedish
and and i'm having that checked by a
teacher i'm not just assuming that
uh assuming that i'm right but um
yeah that sort of stuff i i
if i'm being brutally honest with my
level i think it's probably at around
a
obviously it's not as fluent but it's
it's around the mental level of a of an
early
what we in australia would call high
school so like 10 11 12 years old it's
that's about
as uh what's the word eloquently as i
can express myself in swedish so so i
need to think about what a 10 11 12 13
year old would do a school
um interest so i'm probably not quite up
to dissertations and things yeah i mean
i could attempt that but i think that
would be at the point where the
difficulty is a little bit inefficient
because i i would be spending so much
time thinking oh what's this and
interesting yeah so you need some
deliberate practice right absolutely to
go to the to the upper level because i
recently watched an interview where
krashen talks about the fact that you
need just to get input as much as you
can and then
output doesn't serve the purpose i do
believe well i i do believe that he has
a point
when it comes to input input the
so-called input hypothesis
meaning the more the more exposure input
you get the better or the merrier
i also believe that in the in the power
of deliberate practice
um and um i will put a couple of links
in the description box if you want to
know more about the concept of deliver
practice and there's a lot of
interesting research on that
okay now on to the
the the next question
um
how does physical i don't know if you
like you know working out running
swimming any physical activity and how
does that impact your life and like does
it have any role in language learning do
you do any activities i don't know when
you're working out
do you listen to languages where you go
running maybe in australia it's too hot
to run in the summer i don't know
it is often too hot to run in the summer
but um i used to run quite a lot i
haven't r i i don't exercise as much as
i would like to but i'm trying to
actually set up my uh house so that
even when it's hot i can
get on an exercise bike and be like
watching a series um
because yeah i want to i want to be
learning a language whilst uh exercising
and it's
i i think that exercise is really
important i'm i must admit that i'm at
the moment i'm not great at convincing
myself to do it um
but
at the very least i i do walk with audio
books on
um and then occasionally i just change
it up and just go for a walk or a run
with nothing in my ears and that's quite
refreshing but i think when i do that
all the time i used to never have
anything in my ears when i ran
and then
that got kind of boring
and then i started listening to audio
books and now when i don't do that it's
a nice change so is there's there's ways
that you can vary your your routine but
i mean your but
as language learners i guess we would
value our
our our
mental strength like our you know our
brains our in intellectual capacity um
but
that can't happen without
without the body like you're not not
just like a head a jar
um so
so you need to keep your body healthy
but
i'm i'm not the best i've i will admit
that
um just before luca and i were
discussing that we don't always we don't
always treat our bodies the way that we
would ideally like to
yeah
how about you
yeah well i'm finding it a little bit
difficult to do physical lectures
working out um especially these days
there's a big friction in starting like
everything
the most difficult part is actually in
starting so you have to set up the
environment so that it kind of um
you know helps you
get started i'm finding it difficult
these days to do that even though truth
be told the weather is great for example
for running because i love running i've
been running it for i've been running
for the last 20 years or something
but now because of the kidney stone that
i have i had you know this little
problem in the summer still have it it's
more difficult i try to run but after
after a couple of minutes my back hurts
unfortunately so still have to go to the
doctor but that's a that's a different
matter but um when i do physical
exercise
when i run i
i have to say that i'm not a
fan of
listening to
language podcasts while i'm running i
always connect running with music if i
have to listen to music
if i have if i have to go to the park i
will listen to music but i've
established this simple rule that the
last 10 minutes of my running session is
dedicated to language learning so when i
go back home when i'm
on my way back home for 10 or 15 minutes
i will listen to a podcast and i have
connected working out the working out
session is always connected with polish
so every time that i do a workout
session i'm doing for example i'm
listening to music because it helps me
you know with movement i get excited
but then i
every time i take a shower
if i don't have to
for example wash my hair i have the the
air pods which allows me to listen to a
polish
a polished podcast and then when i i
groom and i do other
space and the time and the activity
dedicated to listening to podcasts in in
in polish so i've connected a number of
activities either before uh the you know
the running or the working out session
and after that that where i spend time
especially listening to languages that i
have let's say at a b1 b2 level so
listening is once you get to that level
it's very easy to connect with other
things
and um so and not only that but also
when you engage in physical activity
then you're you know you're in a good
mood after that you're full of
endorphins whatever they call them so
it's very beneficial for me it clears my
mind for me running as a sort of
motivation you're just in
out there out and about and you're just
enjoying nature and and it helps me also
with with language learning in general
it's important to do it but sometimes we
know that we have to do you know stuff
but it's difficult yeah
anyway
thanks for the answer um we have a
couple of more questions here so are you
an organized person have you become an
organized person what what about getting
your life organized and how has
language running impacted that if if it
has
in general you have a very structured
day you're more like hey you know let's
do whatever whatever comes
um
i'm more organized than i used to be i
wouldn't say that i'm an organized
person overall uh luca luca and i was
supposed to
meet a year ago
and not no we haven't been so
disorganized that it's taken a year to
to help make this happen but we were
supposed to meet a year ago and i got
the day wrong and i went to the movies
um when i was supposed to be with
because i definitely wouldn't call
myself an organized person um
and with regard to organizing my day i
no not really i would i'm gonna say no
i'm not an organized person i was more
organized when i was working a nine to
five and i would generally have to get
to work at about
seven o'clock
um
uh so it was actually more like a seven
to midday or seven to one job
um i was organized then but
and i ironically actually spent a little
bit more time learning languages then
because i always had an hour an hour
trip each way
the short answer is no
[Laughter]
i try i'm always productive i'm a
productive person i'm not always
organized in how i do that sometimes i'm
editing videos at one in the morning
other times
i'm still watching a series in swedish
at one in the morning
i'm i'm never doing nothing which is
good
but i'm never doing the same thing at
the same time of day if that's what you
call organized and the reason that one
one of the many reasons that i'm
standing is that the ceiling is much
cleaner than the floor
so
gotcha
i know the answer to this but
yeah yeah i'm not gonna delve into that
that much uh when it comes to my
organization um i'm probably going to
make a video about that actually i have
but we still have to publish it i'm kind
of an organized person so i always have
like blocks of time during the day
and it serves me well but you don't have
to be that organized i remember the
people who take a look at my calendar go
like oh my god how do you how do you
live like that you know but um i believe
that there's this kind of stereotype
that if you plan everything then your
life doesn't have flexibility anymore i
don't believe that it can give you more
flexibility if you know how to do it so
i'm i've become more flexible with time
i understood that if you block every
single minute your plans or your plan
never goes exactly as you had planned
so i've learned to be structured but
also to give uh you know to give a
little
to give space to create space for more
stuff you know in just in case plan b
and everything else okay one last
question before we get into the q a
because you guys asked a lot of
interesting questions you want to keep
it you know
we want to keep this video relatively
acceptably uh you know at an acceptable
length so to speak um let's talk about
motivation motivation in general and
motivation in language learning um
what do you do to stay motivated like
you've been learning swedish for how
long you've been learning swedish more
or
less
almost five years total i would say two
years of that i was reasonably focused
on french like more focused on french
than on swedish
but 18 months now just swedish
okay have you had a
how have you kept the motivation so high
have you had any motivation dip and
and do you have any tips or pieces of
advice for those who
get unmotivated um in
you know in the long path along the long
path of language learning
um i've got a few that are like you can
take or leave um
one of them is that i've got all these
like
series i want to watch books i want to
read
like you know series either in swedish
or like a
actually a kids show but like a good
kids show dubbed into swedish and books
i want to read so i just generally just
go the next thing the next thing so i
finish one book and i just say oh i
really wanted to read that book um so
the hard part now is deciding when to
stop that and and to go back to french
because i do want to do that at some
point too um
i'm looking over here at my bookshelf
that's uh so that's one thing is just to
have these tasks and to see that as the
value in itself but that doesn't always
work um
another one is like i think it's
sometimes called the pay-per-click
method
um
by some salesman who who had like a jar
of paper clips on his on his desk and so
that he could see how many sales calls
he was making he would just move one
paper clip to the other jar every
morning uh that and until he was done
and that was the thing so not worrying
about the results so much like am i not
wearing oh am i getting better at
swedish have i reached this milestone
because milestones are very hard to
measure in language learning um so i'm
doing like a really big version of that
with uh these seeds that i have in a
little
jar where every hour of swedish i do
whether it's input output
deliberate practice anything and every
hour i spend on swedish i move a seed
over
and i know that when i finished that
thing of seeds my swedish will be a lot
better than it is now so and that's what
i want i don't know i don't i can't
measure a thing of how good would a
wheel um
that's
that's my tips but you you're gonna have
dips in motivation and you can
um
you can yeah that's okay i guess is what
i want to say
i think it's normal to have different
motivations sometimes you tell yourself
what the heck am i doing why am i doing
that right so
my very short piece of advice is that
when that happens i think you should
focus more on the steps rather than
thinking about the peak of the mountain
because if you're constantly thinking
when am i going to get there and you
focus too much on goals then you lose
sight of the systems that make those
goals reaching those goals possible and
i believe that that's the first thing
and the second thing is that it's if you
get unmotivated you're doing something
wrong and you should change the way you
learn whether the material you're
engaging in or the way you're doing it
i think that plays a role so
thank you lamont this was very
interesting um and now let's start with
some of the questions that i have here i
don't have my contact lenses so
i um
let's let's take a look at the first
question
so
pepe's world is it normal when learning
a language to have difficulty
understanding accents you're not used to
i've been learning spanish for about
three years now and sometimes it's not
easy for me to understand certain
accents what's what's your short answer
to that
good answer is yes very normal three
years is not even that long unless
you've been going like all spanish all
the time kind of thing um you
three years you shouldn't be expected to
be an expert on all the languages that
exist especially in spanish there's got
to be hundreds um
and also that i wouldn't
it in the first kind of well the first
stages up until a b2 level even it would
be ideal if you didn't have too much
exposure to different accents and you
focused on one accent because i still
struggle to understand norwegian
which i guess you could consider like an
extreme accent of swedish
so
that's yeah
i i fully agree i fully agree with
lamont
i think you should stick to one accent
when when you start and then
if you don't understand accents within
the spanish world it's pretty normal i
think the chilean accent you know from
chile is infamous for being very
difficult if you haven't been exposed to
that so it's completely normal don't
worry about it just keep getting exposed
to the language as much as you can and
then if you want to understand a
specific accent then get exposed to that
accent and you will understand it in no
time
so um
brew bf sorry for butchering your name i
can't really see here i'm a b b 2
c 1 level in english i'm at b 2
c 1 level in english i'm currently doing
some bi-directional translations for a
few weeks however i feel i'm in i'm in
the intermediate plateau and is it
really difficult to measure my progress
in english how can i overcome that you
were saying that before how can you
measure
actually uh the progress progress in a
complex skill such as second language
acquisition acquiring a second language
well luca might disagree with me on this
but i would say
to not really worry about measuring it
because i think it's very difficult to
measure like i was saying before that a
swedish 10 year old is much more fluent
than i am
but
i would probably
do better on an exam meant for
university students or something because
they're totally different skill sets so
i i wouldn't worry so much about it's
it's it's very hard to measure
who
whether you've gotten good at a language
or whatever so at that level if you
really are b2 to c1 especially if c1 i
would worry about developing specific
skills that you would like to have so if
you would like to be really good at
talking about technology or i.t or
global warming or the climate in general
or something then develop that skill and
and don't worry so much about
how good you are at english as a whole
i think lemon i don't disagree at all
with you i agree i agree with everything
the only thing i would add in this
regard is i don't know if you ever heard
of a book which is really interesting
which is called measure what matters
and language learning is indeed a
complex skill that is difficult to
to measure i think that if you can
measure something it could be for
example the amount of hours you spend or
what you do you can measure there are
some things that you can measure you can
put in numbers if it helps you if it
gives you a sense of direction
and what i normally do is that i
actually do not measure my skills
because it's it's really difficult but i
do do i do two things first of all i
keep a journal where right what i do
every day and the amount of time um you
know that i spend engaging in in these
activities like for example in greek and
hungarian um but i also write on and off
comments that where when i have eureka
moment so you can't
you know as i said before you can't
really measure progress but you can
write sometimes oh i actually started
understanding words in a movie i
remember when i was watching
um
i uh i don't remember exactly now the
name of the movie i think you you
probably know it it's a
it's a movie about uh it's a funny movie
about the police in sweden
uh and
cops and the main actor i think he's
from lebanon he he made a
you know he made another movie before
that that i really liked that was the
very first movie that i watched together
with sorry guys this is in the first
word is the f word in english but it's
the the name of the thing is it's called
[ __ ] omo
which was a movie that marked me uh when
i watched it i remember back in the day
i i you know i found the script in
swedish and i was going through the
entire script
um
anyway
eureka moments where you suddenly
understand stuff i remember i watched i
started watching after a year learning
the language and i said oh my god i
actually understand what they're saying
and so i think if you keep track of the
amount of time that you spend or the
activities that you are engaging in and
you jot down some comments on and off
on how you're doing things if you can
improve them or eureka moments that's an
indirect way of measuring your progress
because measuring
uh something like language learning is
really difficult at least directly in
terms of numbers that's why i think
um so how important do you this is
beyond the basics in polish interesting
name uh how important do you find the
process of constructing your own
sentences rather than being spoon-fed
ones through texts and apps or doesn't
matter is seeing the words on the page
enough or do we need to actively be
training our ability to translate
without any crutches slash visual aids
i was a little bit confused by this
question because the end of it seems to
imply that when we're speaking we would
be translating
or maybe maybe he means um because i
know this
guy sort of i know who he is um
uh maybe he means that when we're
writing uh i i don't know because
outputting i would be trying to avoid
translating and and if there's still a
if you feel a need to translate
um
then i would say you probably need more
input
i don't
my experience with it is that
just a very
a very input-weighted
uh blend of
of input and and speaking
means that you will produce your own
sentences that are still correct
um
and and still sound like what a native
would say
so yes i i think seeing that i don't
think seeing the words on the page but
hearing hearing the words in your ears
and seeing the words on the page i think
that is enough but i think most people
significantly underestimate how much you
need
agreed um for me it's um in language
journey it's neither the this or that
it's this and that so and
if i if i may i would say that
it's important to get exposed to a
number of um
sentences
the more the merrier but then what i
normally do just to give an example is i
take a piece of content that can be a
text and you know a podcast then i take
specific words or actually fragments of
that podcast they put them into a
notebook gonna make a video about that
because people have been asking me and
then i basically
um make sure that i write fragments that
are flexible enough so that i can create
my own sentences so it's a i bridge the
two worlds i
i i expose myself to send to sentences
within a specific context i get them out
of the page so to speak and i transfer
the information into a notebook and then
i use them to have a meaningful
conversation either with myself or a
tutor telling about the content of the
podcast so that i can you know i get the
best of both worlds so to speak but
again i would get exposed to a lot of
you know the language and the more the
merrier
um
language guide elena or elena this is
the it would be the italian
pronunciation that's my sister's name
elena do you think it's possible to
learn a language if you wear many hats
in life like being a mother working at
home parents etc etc being a parent blah
blah blah
i really liked this question um because
i think it acknowledges the reality that
it's very difficult it's not i i think
there's a lot of uh
talk out there i'm sort of i don't want
to
just mention anyone specifically but i
think there's a lot of this idea it's
like oh you you know you can just do it
if you put your mind to it and you can
but you
there is actually a reality to your life
and
i found we were talking before about
organization i found that i need to be
as organized as
my life is complex so back when i first
started learning swedish i i did heaps i
did like three or four hours a day and i
did that with ease because i didn't have
anything else that i was really doing um
you you could say i was
i
i was a loser i didn't have anything
going on so i was just just learning
swedish um but but now i i spend i will
freely admit i spend a lot of time
making videos it was totally up to me i
would just learn learn languages for
like eight hours a day but i've have a
living to make and everything so i'd
spend a lot of time making videos i also
have two kids um i
you need to be very deliberate with your
time
and and it
it's possible
i think when when you're not
when you're not as good as you could be
in terms of being deliberate with your
time
it's
you you feel like you're in this
permanent place of like feeling like i'm
i'm getting the most out of my time that
i possibly could be but then like when i
when i saw luca's timetable
i was like what the heck is going on the
first time we met he ran straight from
straight from speaking to me straight to
to a danish lesson
and and i was like this guy really
has completely filled his life with with
stuff that he's doing so i
i think that you can
but it is difficult um
and
and you also need to set up systems that
work so for example i'm trying to raise
uh well especially my younger son my
older son's it's a bit late for me to
raise him now but he also watches with
us we we watch stuff in swedish so i
watch i raise my youngest son in swedish
as much as i can which then gives me
time in swedish as well
and i don't know i certainly wouldn't
get as much swedish as i do
if i hadn't made that choice so you've
got to put in realistic things and also
i've dropped like i don't read in
english anymore people give me books
one person in particular gives me a lot
of books they're like i think you'll
enjoy this and i'm like i'm not going to
read that because it's in english
so i even read the stuff that luca's
recommending now like stuff like atomic
habits and whatnot i i'll read that in
swedish as well
fantastic great
great um just if i can chime in chime in
um it's difficult it's difficult
especially if you have a family but i i
believe you can always squeeze in 10
minutes if you can for example i have an
american
student of mine she's she's traveling
all around the world she has two kids so
she's very busy but at the same time she
started i you know we started talking
about it and she realized that
um you know it's about
making it a priority language journey if
it's a priority for you so she makes the
sacrifice quote unquote um of waking up
earlier when kids are still sleeping and
then she puts in the time but it's
difficult in the long run and i do
understand you have to work on systems
and you have to be consistent if you
really want it you know that's at the
end of the day you have to
you have to want it in the long run
that's a difficult part
um
so this is another really interesting
question
by
this is a difficult silly adrienne
saladrian i'm not sure how to get over
the feeling of being stuck i study an
hour every day but i feel like i'm not
making any progress or i'm not
progressing as quickly as i would like
this is a very very common question like
how do i get unstuck when i got stuck
you know
i guess it would depend i would need to
know more details about what you mean by
stuck but it sounds to me like pretty
common plateau kind of thing whether
it's the intermediate plateau or the
advanced plateau like
um
and that's why i would i would just do
something like the paperclip method or
just say you're going to do like
you'd be going to do another 100 hours
in the next three months so a bit over
an hour a day or
like and it's
you can't really not
not get better if you
if unless you're unless you're like c2
already and you're trying to get very
specifically better which i doubt
then
if you just keep doing an hour every day
you will get better
i don't think anyone progresses as fast
as they
uh
as they feel like they should like i've
just been experimenting in in a new
language in like the last two days
really because i'm testing this app and
so i was testing it with a new language
and
it's
so exciting because i see like literally
every word i've never seen before but
i've at the time that you see them i'm
like i could i could learn that and i
could learn that oh this this language
is easy if you just learn
learn like these thousands of words that
i'm saying that i've never seen before
then i'd speak the language but it's
realistically you can't
you just can't take in more than maybe
at this stage 15 20 words a day or for
you it might be eight words a day
because you're already more advanced i
don't know but it's
no one i don't think anyone's out there
thinking yeah i'm i'm smashing this i'm
i'm going to be where i want to be
in a month's time it just takes a long
time
and i think unless you worry about how
long it takes the faster you go like
i've sort of started relaxing about my
swedish recently and i had a lesson the
other night and
it was flowing out like never before i
don't know what it was but
get into the floor and relax stop
thinking about it stop worrying about it
yeah but it's a very hard answer to
accept you just stop thinking about it
but
yeah well no well no that's that's
that's fair enough actually um it's it's
a very uh actually complex answer to
answer it would take um it would take
quite a long time to answer properly now
we want to cover other other questions
because we're running out of time here
but to you know uh to
to be concise to make a long story short
for me
um it's like when you want to lose
weight you take you took a look at
yourself in the mirror and you don't see
any change day by day but actually you
do so you should stop worrying about it
focus on the system and most of all as i
said before make sure that you reflect
upon your language learning what am i
doing are you doing it correctly are you
doing things automatically are you doing
things just because you heard that these
things
need to be done at this stage so take
your language learning in your hands
think about what works for you because
everyone is slightly different or
different and then you will make
progress if you put in the work and if
you work if you think long term
so here's a few questions from youtube
so we we covered some questions from
instagram
uh let me see this is a very long
question i'll read the first part of it
by day the 13th interesting name would
you guys say it's beneficial to just
listen to the sounds of a language that
you want to learn for a period of time
before even getting into actually trying
to learn and understand the language so
for example you would simply listen to
your target language for about six
months for a year get accustomed to the
sense of the language and only then get
into the language i do wonder if it will
lead to better results in the long run
an interesting question
i've heard anecdotes that it does um so
that i spoke to one swedish guy who said
that the only non-native swedish speaker
he'd ever met who sounded like a native
so that's a very very big call
the only one he'd ever met did that he
just listened to swedish for like six
months without ever
actually attempting to speak it and then
started moving towards actually learning
how the language works and um
but
even
matt
versus japan who's like you know pretty
extreme in his methodology even he said
well that's a pretty like you've really
got to have faith that that's going to
work if you're if you're going to
attempt that um because okay you might
it's not a big deal to just listen to a
language for six months if you're not
doing anything else but if i'm not
totally positive that's going to work
then
i'm probably going to try actually
understanding it and everything
i certainly think it's kind of an
extreme version of the input
hypothesis or the input heavy version um
so whether you whether you could cope
with that and whether you would be okay
if that maybe didn't work out the way
you'd hoped
i don't know
fair enough i i agree with you so i
don't need to add anything else
um
i think you should start learning the
language as far as i'm concerned you can
listen to the language maybe for for one
week or two weeks but then you know
you you're an adult you can actually use
scripts and etc so i that's what i would
do i get into it immediately but to each
his own as they say
um
um so
what is b2 for you i think we covered
that but you know we use
maybe we were getting into a you know
like a this is a opening a candle
um
what is b2 for you how do you know that
you're good enough in one language that
it can become maintenance phase that it
can become maintenance phase and you can
start a new one this is what she
literally wrote
this is an interesting question how do
you know okay now i'm good enough that i
can i can just maintain the language
um
i really don't know i'm not good at this
because um
i
i'm working on that right now like as we
speak i'm working on is it can i like is
this a good time for me to go back to
french and i'm pretty like i'm pretty
confident that my swedish is at c1
um
like in terms of measuring there's a
like with certain things you can measure
and go do i tick that box do i tick that
box i'm pretty confident that my swedish
is a c1 but still i feel
when i compare my swedish to my english
i think well it's not very good and it
makes me want to get better at swedish
so i
i
i don't know but some i know some people
have these things like could you learn i
think richard simcott has said
could you learn you he calls it like a
stable language or a base language or
something um
oh anchor language that's it
the one of the measures of it is could
you learn a third language or whatever
language you're up to through that
language
um
so but
luca would luca would know more about
this than me because he has languages at
at like various levels i just have
swedish and english really so
in my case i think it
it's just when you feel it meaning that
again it's difficult to gauge uh exactly
your skills so when i feel like i i can
do certain things like i can have a
conversation with
people on the street or i can start
understanding movies or i can start
understanding the content of podcasts
that are relatively complex that's a
moment where i think i can start
maintaining a language at least by
listening to it
and it's a it's a difficult it's a it's
a complex
question to answer so the the short the
short version is that when you feel it
when you're able to do certain things
like understanding the language more or
less around you without you know the aid
of a script or visual aids like
subtitles and when you start engaging in
conversations so you feel confident
enough that's the moment where i feel
like i can actually start
getting into maintenance mode if i want
to or just to get into deliberate
practice and keep improving this is a
very short answer it takes more time but
we're running out of time i wanted to go
through one last question here we have
more questions guys sorry for not
covering all of them but it's just a
matter of time if you're interested we
can always make another video with
lamont um
how much time do you spend per day
listening to and reading a language as
you are in the process of learning
uh
as you are in the process of learning it
i'm doing about 30 minutes of listening
without taking notes and 10 minutes of
listening and taking notes with harder
material is that enough
i i think that's actually pretty good at
first because i i have this theory that
it's
not if if you just throw in like six
hours a day at the start then a lot of
that goes to waste because
a lot of that time is you spent your
brain just like filtering out things
that it can't uh it can't
ask it can't
your brain that those things are
important because it's like you just
can't learn that quickly so if you throw
in six hours a day
of input for example it it might
actually work out to an hour and a half
a day that your brain actually can take
any of that in so 30 to 40 minutes
especially if 30 minutes of those are
like that you're doing something
deliberate and trying to
learn new things
i think is good
i think after
a while when you start being able to
understand things to a to a certain
extent without any aid just just hearing
it
or just reading it
then it's good to try to step that up
um one just to
just to make the language more a part of
your life but two
because you're trying to sort of
override some base assumptions that
your br especially if this is your first
foreign language um you're trying to
override
these kind of assumptions that like oh
this is how words go together this is
this is how it works in english so this
must be how it works in whatever you're
trying to learn um
and
and
just a ton of like
uh no it's not impossible for everyone
but bombarding your brain with the
language once you reach a certain level
maybe b1 i think is a good idea if it's
possible
and that's why if if you learn a fair
bit before you say move to the country
then you generally end up speaking the
language well
but if you don't learn anything when you
move to before you move to the country
and then you might get in a situation
where you just speak english all the
time
okay great fantastic great answer my
short very short answer to that is
you have to ask yourself is that enough
for you like there's no good enough or
you know the more the merrier but then
you have to be realistic with your time
and energy if you can do 30 minutes
that's great 30 minutes a day i think
the most important thing is frequency
doing it every day if you can do it 15
30 minutes it's great if you can do a
little bit more that's even better you
get there faster but the more important
thing is do it every day and get exposed
to interesting
and compelling content thank you so much
lamont it's been great to have you
um where can people find you
uh they can find me at youtube.com
days of french
in swedish and not not and um
um but if you just punch into youtube
days of french and swedish or days of
french in swedish it will come up
um
yeah it's only youtube at the moment so
gotcha very interesting channel i highly
recommend it and your your style your
editing style
fascinates me i have to learn a thing or
two about that
um thank you so much again lamont have a
fantastic night because it's night in
australia and it's morning here and i
will see you soon here on youtube bye
bye thank you
[Music]